jesus christ there's been no spider-man
news for like a day
for hours now i've been stressing out
and what are we gonna get
more who else has been catching when is
it coming out
okay so this isn't casting news but
apparently there's a new
spider-man mcu deal three more
movies what sony and disney deal we're
gonna watch the report
hailed from our friend what's his name
warren winslow warren cosmic
warren i was i was also thinking winslow
let's
watch this
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
mcu the hype of spider-man 3
is real it's so real and big that it
looks like we have
another negotiation for spider-man
between sony and marvel studio slash
disney
now i'm sure most of you remember the
recent negotiations between
sony and disney that we had not too long
ago that put everybody on edge and
everybody was really afraid
everybody was going to be out of the mcu
ultimately that wasn't the case sony and
marvel came to a deal and spider-man
is still in the mcu but it does appear
like we have a new deal
in the works right now let's hear it
this is coming from two different
sources and the first one is mikey
sutton
gegossity.com if you're good old mikey i
was an insider during the last
negotiations between sony and disney
he kept us up to date with what was
really happening he was in the air vents
verge of a new deal for spider-man's
rights but no need to fear as this
is actually good news this could
actually mean more spider-man film
collaborations between sony and marvel
and new live
action tv shows as well possibly on
disney playlists live
action tv shows huh but sources say the
deal will keep spider-man in the marvel
cinematic universe for an
additional three solo movies with an
option for
more we might get a spider-man 4. the
spider-man
homecoming trilogy era which is said
and move on to peter parker's college
years all of course meanwhile
being a part of the avengers possibly
going on to lead the avengers or
the young avengers and still a fugitive
and in school they're hearing the same
exact rumor
they said on their podcast that marvel
studios extended the spider-man deal
with sony due to the web slinger playing
a pivotal role
in the future of the marvel cinematic
universe now the fact that sony and
disney are working a new deal doesn't
really come as that big of a surprise
as things heat up for spider-man 3 more
and more people are getting more and
more excited for it each and every day
and it seems like
every day a new report comes out for
spider-man 3 that gets the fans super
pumped and right now it's kind of all
anybody can really talk about
so of course tom holland has a very huge
role in the marvel cinematic universe
moving forward after spider-man 3
especially if you consider what's going
to happen in spider-man 3 with the
multiverse and right now if the reports
for tom holland's current contract are
accurate
that means he only has one more solo
film and a group film left with the
contract between sony and disney
and even though spider-man 3 is looking
to be oh man
big movie with many different characters
that's going to be his solo film
then he'll most likely be in a new
avengers film and that's going to be it
and that's all going to be within the
next few years which isn't a very long
future in the marvel cinematics
successful british movie of course
they're doing it right now because the
hype for spider-man 3
is getting bigger and bigger every day
so they want to get this deal locked
down before the release of spider-man 3
because there is so much more potential
with spider-man in the marvel cinematic
universe than we already have
there's many different routes that they
can go down in the movies but also on a
live action show all the different
series that are going to be coming down
the line
plus so when kevin feige
talking about the upcoming disney plus
series she-hulk he revealed that tatiana
miscellany is going to be playing
she-hulk slash jennifer walters and he
did reveal that mark ruffalo will be in
the series as well as the hulk
along with a bunch of other people who
might show up
william defoe sandman
so perhaps she could show up in
spider-man 3 and then spider-man could
show up in the she-hulk disney plus
series
and not to mention they'll probably want
tom hawks on trial again
disney plus show that was recently
announced nick fury and talos are going
to be in the show and the last time we
saw
talos he was with spider-man who we
thought was nick fury the entire time
helping spider-man slash peter parker
out ended up actually being talos and
his wife
oh yeah that's a good call good point
spider-man to be
in that series and points and you
probably want to use him in a series
like that in other series as well
which is probably of course his new deal
so they can put tom hall and spider-man
in
more projects for marvel studios and at
the end of the day it works out better
for marvel
and sony because they all make money
that's what it's about and tom holland
staying within
the marvel cinematic universe so unlike
last time this is actually a good thing
that a new deal between
sony and disney slash marvel studios is
being worked out for tom holland
spider-man
in the marvel cinematic universe what
future projects would you like to see
tom holland spider-man in
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on
the ned lead show
there is the main supporting character
tomorrow for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof and i also think they got to
bring back
a team daryl show team daryl disney plus
series
and then peter parker maybe takes place
during the spider-man 3 events he's on
the run
and then he has to go crash at daryl's
place how great would that how great
would that be
dude that's a real pitch i have i'm
starting the petition change.org slash
the daryl show revival just come sign up
come come help don't tease my penis like
that i'm sorry i'll
well actually this all lines up with the
original plan that i remember feige
forever ago
saying that they wanted to do many
spider-man movies and then yeah
after that whole debuggle that did occur
where
you know i'm talking about all right the
contract was was very limited on the
amount of appearances and such
so going back a little bit more to the
original drawing board
i think it's really cool getting to
fulfill that vision that feige
originally had in mind for spider-man to
really
deal with him in his high school years
watch him age watch him go to his
college years that all sounds
super gravy to me and i love the idea of
him appearing in a secret invasion show
i didn't even think about that
of oh yeah that's right you see that
post-credit scene
in spider-man far from home it makes
sense
it makes sense if he somehow did appear
there i would
love that i wouldn't want him to be the
star of it maybe like an episode or two
it would be cool it's supposed to be a
series if i'm not mistaken yeah
which sounds awesome but yeah i mean
more spider-man is never a bad thing in
my mind i'm always more excited
for more spidey dude this all sounds
cool i mean
to get a live action tv show amongst all
this
that'd be bold i would love to see that
you know we've gotten several spider-man
animated shows
obviously no spider i don't think they
would do it with
tom holland i think it would be a good
opportunity to get there are so many
other
spider-man characters who can take up
that mantle and i mean we've already
had miles morales in his own animated
movie and whatnot and there are other
iterations of the character too i mean i
think it would be cool to bring in
somebody new even if that somebody is
gonna meet up with peter at some point
in the mcu or whatever
or maybe if it wasn't even peter parker
i wouldn't even say miles morales uh i
would
say like menu it could be the spider
gwen it could it could be one of the
many characters that are other
spider-man renditions i don't know how
much that would
mess with the mcu timeline but they're
opening up the multiverse
so they could just take one of those
other spider-man characters
and just make a show about them but the
thing about it is
i think they want these disney plus
series like
you know the the groot show
they want these disney plus series to
tie heavily into the movies to feel as
integral to the viewing experience as
possible so i don't know how much an
alt universe spider-man character would
be in the drawing board but that's
something i would personally like to see
to answer the question that warren posed
here in the video
but damn man where where the hell are
like where's the venom talk
we need anything about that all these
things discussion
it's like sony's doing their own thing
it seems like feige is not
interested in it that's like the vibe
i'm getting is because
it's such a sony specific type
of venom that i feel like foggy just
wants
nothing to do with that version at all
even though i'm like but come on man
we're doing spider-man we're getting a
gazillion characters in spider-man 3.
we need to start talking about when
venom's gonna start coming in here i
mean we really do because i mean if
anything was proven by that movie it's
at least that tom hardy and that
character have enough appeal to move
around and i feel like
they could easily incorporate him in a
more mcu-type
territory in a way that complements
their movies and allows him to go back
and
do whatever sony wants to do with their
full control or venom or whatever
but even the possibility that could open
up to him popping up on one of these
shows or something like that like i
think this is just the next logical
conclusion is like once they figured it
out
and spider-man far from home was a big
big success and now there's all this
rumors about
everything in the spider verse just
seems natural that yeah they would want
to keep this working relationship on the
positive and growing and open to
a bunch of other things because they're
calling this what three movies and some
tv show appearances but really it could
be
i've imagined just about anything it's
exciting that we'll actually get a
spider-man 4
film yeah at some point i think that's
just a nice honorary thing
well i have broken it what i love is how
tom holland just seems like he's in it
for the long haul
yeah you know you get that sense of toby
mcguire like i'm ready to hang this up
andrew garfield seemed like he was
already hanging up a little bit early
yeah and
i could see you a lot with these actors
who feel like ah it's
you know i'm getting tired of this but
tom holland seems like he has zero
interest and ever leaving spider-man
behind us always looks like he just got
cast
that excited i think that's a big part
of why we love him it seems to go so
hand in hand with our love for
spider-man
and he seems to really share that all
right guys well with all this spider-man
talk what spider-man type of property do
you want to see is it spider-man venom
crossover
is it spider-man show what is it let us
know down below
subscribe to cosmic wonder subscribe to
the real rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least
[Music]
wow okay now i'm going to stand up and
talk directly this is your asmr
shout out i love you i love you
you're like the indian peter parker i
want you to know
that no matter what happens no matter
what happens
you could even sleep with my fiance
that's right i will
always be there for you i will always
love you all
no matter what you could kill my brother
and i will
always love you you could poop on my mom
and i will
love you even more i can vouch i kind of
like it yeah so no matter what
mirage no matter no matter what don't
don't you even think don't forget it i
ever will always be by your side okay
and i'll be behind the both of you with
a candy because
the name niraj narada it starts with an
n
because that means never ever
ever will i never ever leave niraj
krishnan
ever ever long is how long i will stay
with sarah
i love you that's the end of
what n means it's a whole phrase merry
christmas
enjoy your family don't forget to slap
my sister
[Music]
mm-hmm